yeah welcome to a new five-minute game
and it's just one guitar play too
numerous times already someone requested
landing grant Dutch maybe odd get one
maybe yeah okay and I think he wanted me
to play with 96 I have really only know
that this exists but I don't turn I
think what needs to cook d5 if you want
to play for for something yeah this
doesn't look too bad it probably takes
now oh yeah no idea before probably so
it's a nice advantage in space the
question is how to how to continue don't
go nitey seven maybe maybe 97 and
tending c65 now he really needs to go f3
I don't think that slow moves are our
two great allowing me to place is 65
should be a should be okay for me or
maybe d5 instantly okay yeah this is
maybe an alternative so possible okay
how to continue yeah f3 is something ok
but Mary maybe i can go night to g6 by
night on e 7s radio not a great piece
he's playing this AB it's a bit slow
wearing slowly spending lots of time to
improve pieces on e4 you went to e1 now
to see to him I mean if you go to d4 you
could have done that immediately now I
could you he couldn't take Ansari time
I'm talking nonsense okay yeah we'll
probably still f3 and threatening at for
now at least I think that this is a
threat
but the three years of course a double
agent sometimes in those positions with
f5 who are black has played at five it
is an idea simply to to put the light on
his six and give up a pawn but usually
White's need some activity for the light
squared Bishop stew Bishop to do that
this is a surprising move I can make in
the way for now what is some what is the
big big problem 96 now but stopped
really threatening much but I'm probably
wow why this this must be great for
black
okay if I take g3 now and play night to
h5 this looks and looks terrible
I've 94 I didn't really consider 94 but
I'm not sure that it's really a problem
should have should have taken a bit more
time but this this looks like what if i
go here and Nigeria lee a bit much
maybe it looks I know it looks
ridiculous but maybe even taking as an
idea just to add I've got two nights
actually for one job being on a four and
this is not great but it's it so it's a
bit of a defensive piece okay we're just
let's just let's just go go here rookie
one is it's hard to hard to believe okay
no h5 really invading with all those
pieces
yeah for the same disaster I actually
thought I could just take here yeah now
Queen five threatening 92 mate I don't
really see how here how I should defend
that it's double check mate and King
edge too I know King edge too i should
have someone
are 93 years actually of course 92 is
winning but I don't don't see a mate yet
and yeah probably i'm i'm very very
stupid up night 8 39 f 2 wins two queen
at least I don't see a mate this is so
this is funny
yeah I don't seem a time probably just
blind here Jack White forfeits due to
disconnection yeah well I understand it
was suddenly quite frustrating to to
have this experience is wide um he
disconnected I didn't see a mate this is
very embarrassing there should be a maid
I cannot believe there isn't one the
computer actually wants to win the Queen
as well this is funny yeah plus 10 but
it doesn't spot am a debt it's really
hard really hard to believe that they
should be it made now okay you win the
green at her phone still having a tech
going yeah well I played some some very
strange move here of course you must go
94 and it's not even so clear i played
this too quickly i can i can do other
things IAM neither h form or 95 or just
them slightly out of the the move order
are Queenie fibers of strong with 25
okay i played this rather quickly but
now you know of course needs to go here
and this isn't this isn't immediately
obvious how blackest winning maybe he
isn't him it's not clear his got two
good nights this night protect g3 of
course black has multitude of trixie i
mean white for instance cannot easily
take III because g3 then this is hanging
because the pin but it's not so clear
what what my next move is
hmm I know the computer actually wants
to go rookie aid which looks I don't
know what the ideas of the smooth it
looks really strange what were why is
this better than I don't know I mean lkh
sixes it's not really am does it have a
point rookie and then it wants to go
look do you want and visually frightened
yeah better better would have been a
queen e5 this is this is really good and
understandable suggestion by the comp
just attacking this and of course the
defensive moves 94 now i can just take
it and the ideas on king here there's
this one whose is nice yeah but this is
more more like something you can play
enum in a long time control game that's
this oops no II five and then Queen h2
and blackest black ass Winningham
there's no way to defend this computer
wants to play something like this and
this is of course utterly depressing
it's just your position is full of pins
at holes alright thanks for watching